I think I have to if I was I'd like to
say three hours a day but that you know
probably in the day when I'm around my
desk and not you know in New York City
or something but I think I read more
than most people in those younger than
me who are so busy doing things so I
have the leisure time actually to to
read and I think that's what we've lost
now in sort of science today is leisure
quickly I had plenty of leisure because
nothing was happening we're trying to
find the DNA structure stiffness is the
one hundreds of you know new facts
appearing here you know almost every
week that we might learn about and so
now people lead defensively we want to
be sure that they're your people think
they're experts so there was a more and
more narrow experts and not fair broad I
still can't get over when I was a large
pharmaceutical company they half
jokingly but I'm sure the reality was
true they had a thousand PhD technicians
this is you got your PhD you were just a
technician no we were hiring you through
a very narrow thing not show any you
know big thoughts at all so with so many
facts but I missed our thinkers the who
you would say or smart I was a boy you
know smart people respected now is your
people do things who doors and often you
find that you know
there hadn't been one person doing it
their 50 names on the paper and our
famous paper at Francis mine could have
included Morris Wilkins name on it
because he was really part of a you
didn't make the final discovery but he
was you know part of the step just
before so we asked him to put his name
on the paper and I said no it had been a
three-person paper but the I'm worried
about people really thinking big I don't
find many people who do so now the when
I was a student at the University of
Chicago Rahm touches as we said the
function of the college of the
University of Chicago was to prepare you
for greatness he used those words
because our education was largely we
need the great books and you were
reading the great books not to be a
teacher but to let you go beyond the
great books and produce another great
book so that was how he saw of course he
would know that that wouldn't happen
very often but it was still there that
and it's certainly
in dreams of people you know that they
do something big
most the time to keep it secret because
yeah it's so unrealistic
and often and then you get braggarts who
tell you they're doing something great
and you don't believe them
but nonetheless you know in some sort of
quiet way you should have big dreams
I think stop having 50 names on a paper
just you know accept the fact the rest
really didn't think at all about us and
you should really wish you know cheaper
we're just technicians in in you know in
a real sense in the reserve authorship
for people who put together the
sentences I mean you know you know what
the gospel is the answer
whereas I compute you know various axis
factories with the mother of a scientist
now and has her son ten over people were
here there are 20 other people on the
paper and she'd wonder is he going
anywhere so and and another problem
maybe though he goes against everything
we now say we may be trained to when a
scientist that is we're training people
who really don't want to think they just
want to have jobs and they consume money
and so you lose some you know if you cut
out people didn't have real dreams but
if you go into science I think you know
they're going with the dream you know
that maybe you two would get a Nobel
Prize it's not that you know I went in I
thought I was very bright and I was
going to get one but our confessional
you know I knew what it was and quick
games he was otherwise for the moment I
saw that structure I thought we're going
to get a Nobel Prize you know that was
within hidden if I finished school
obvious